المركبه دراغون تعود الى الارض وعلى متنها
رائد فضاء السعوديين بعد رحله استغرقت
عشره ايام بهدف اجراء تجارب علميه
قانونه سقف الدين يمر من لجنه القواعد في
انتظار تصويت مجلس النواب ثم مجلس الشيوخ
والصيدنات دوليه كوريا الشماليه تقول ان
قمر الاستطلاع العسكري الذي اطلقته تحطم
في البحر
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه فاذا مراسل
العربيه عن عوده مهمه الفضاء اي اكس اثنين
التي تحمل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين ريانه
برناوي وعلي القرني على متن المركبه
الفضائيه دراغون الى الارض بعد رحله لعشره
ايام في الفضاء اضاف ان المركبه دراغون
هبطت بسلام قباله سواحل الولايات فلوريدا
الامريكيه بعد اثنتي عشره ساعه استغرقتها
رحله العوده
مررت لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروع قانون السقف الدين وصوت
سبعه اعضاء في او سبعه اعضاء في اللجنه
لصالح المشروع وسته اعداد ضده ستكون
الخطوه الثانيه تصويت على المشروع في مجلس
النواب وسط اعتراضات من التقدميين
والمحافظين ليرسل بعد ذلك الى مجلس الشيوخ
ويحشد قاده الكونجرس المشرعين لتمرير
المشروع قبل الخامس من يونيو لتجنب تخلف
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
انا لازعم انني اثق بما سيفعله الكونجرس
تحدثت الى عدد من المشرعين ويبدو لي الوضع
جيدا وسننتظر التصويت
اتفاق سقف الدين ينص على تعليق الالتزام
بحد الدين البالغ 31 تريليونان و400 مليار
دولار حتى يناير 2025 مقابل تخفيض بعض
جوانب الانفاق الفيدرالي
لتتمكن الحكومه الامريكيه من تسديد ديونها
والابقاء على مستوى الانفاق التقديري
وزيادته عام 2025 بنسبه واحد في المئه وهي
اموال يتم توجيهها الى الاسكان والتعليم
وغيرها من البرامج الفيدراليه
منح مجلس النواب 72 ساعه للاطلاع على
مشروع القانون قبل التصويت عليه
لكن الاتفاق لم يتضمن التخفيضات الكبيره
التي يريدها الجمهوريون
صراحه المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس الامريكي كان واضحا منذ فتره طويله
في دعمه لبيع مقاتلات اف 16 لتركيا مؤكده
ان موافقه التركي على انضمام السويد
الناتو ليست شرطا من اجل بيع هذه
المقاتلات لانقره
فيما يتعلق بمساله طائرات اف 16 ومبيعاتها
الى تركيا وربطها بموافقه انقره على
انضمام السويد الى النيتو اود ان اوضح ان
الرئيس بايدن لا يربط هاتين المسالتين معا
وهو يدعم بيع هذه المقاتلات الى تركيا منذ
فتره طويله ولكنه ايضا اعرب عن رغبته
القويه في ان توافق تركيا على طلب السويد
للانضمام الى النيتو وهو ما نود حدوثه في
اقرب وقت ممكن ولقد طرح الرئيس ذلك خلال
محدثاته مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اصدر والي ولايه البحر الاحمر المكلف فتح
الله الحاج احمد امر طوارئ بحظر التجوال
في بورسودان ينص الامر على حضره جوال في
المدينه من الساعه الحاديه عشره مساء وحتى
الساعه الخامسه صباحا ويعمل بالقرار لمده
تصل الى ثلاثه اشهر
في المقابل تتصاعد تصريحات المتبادله بين
الجيش والدعم السريع قائد الجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان نفى تصريحات الدعم
السريع لان الحرب في السودان ضد جماعه
الاخوان فيما تعاهد باستخدام القنبله التي
وصفها بالمميته والمفرطه في حال لم تتراجع
قوه الدعم السريع
السود
[موسيقى]
ان
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
البرهان قال ان الهدف من الهدنه المبرمه
مع قوات الدعم السريع هو وصول المساعدات
للبسطاء والمتضررين جراء الاشتباكات مع
قوات الدعم السريع
صحيح جهودنا نحن الهدنه دي قاصدين منها ان
الخدمات تمشي لاهلنا الناس البسطاء
المساكين البنات المغتصبا وبيوتهم حرماتها
وماله النهب
وعذبوا وقتلوا بدون ذنب بدون ذنب بدون سبب
يقول الحرب ضد الكيزان وين الكيزان
[تصفيق]
الشعب السوداني
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه ان الصاروخها
الفضائي الذي يحمل قمرا صناعيا للاستطلاع
العسكري يتحطم في البحر الغربي بسبب خلل
فني بحسب ما افادت وكاله الانباء الرسميه
قالت اداره الطيران الوطنيه انها ستجري
تحقيقا معمقا في العيوب الخطره التي تم
اكتشافها خلال عمليه الاطلاق وستتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه للتغلب عليها مشيره الى
انها ستجري عمليه اطلاقا ثانيه في اسرع
وقت ممكن عبر اجراء اختبارات جزئيه مختلفه
ادانت كوريا الجنوبيه بشده احدث عمليه
اطلاق فضائيه لكوريا الشماليه اعلنت ان
جيشها يعمل على انتشار حطام يعتقد انه
للقمر الاصطناعي بدورها الولايات المتحده
اكدت ان رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وفريقه
الامنيه يعملون على تقييم الوضع وقال
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض ادم هوج ان الولايات المتحده تدين
بشده كوريا الشماليه لاطلاقها صاروخا
باليسيا وهو انتهاك صارخ لقرارات مجلس
الامن الدولي ويثير التوترات ويهدد
استقرار الوضع الامني في المنطقه
واشاره واشنطن تحث جميع الدول على ادانه
هذا الاطلاق ودعوه كوريا الشماليه للجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات لاجراء مفاوضات جاده
من جاته قال كبير ومنى مجلس الوزراء
اليابانيين اطلاق كوريا الشماليه لصاروخ
باليسي يعد انتهاكا للعقوبات الدوليه
ويهدد امن اليابان والمنطقه باسرها
والمجتمع الدولي وقد اعرب طوكيو عن
احتجاجها الشديد
اكد امين وعام النيتو ارسال قوه اضافيه من
الحلف الى كوسوفو وذلك عقب الاشتباكات
التي وقعت هناك نتوظفها ايضا انه اصدر
توجيهات بنشر السبع مئه فرد سيكونون في
حاله التاهب كما قال ابي نعام الناتو ان
الاعتداء على قوه الحلف امر غير مقبول وان
على السلطات السلبيه والكزفو اتخاذ
اجراءات لوقف التصعيد
شماليه كوسوفو حيث الازمات السمه المنطقه
تاريخيا تختلف اسباب التصعيد في كل مره
تحديدا في السنوات الاخيره لكن اساسها
يبقى برفض الصرب الذين يشكلون اغلبيه سكان
شمال كوسوفو اعلان الاقليم الاستقلال عن
صربيا الذي تم عام 2008 هذه المواجهات
مستمره منذ ثلاثه ايام بتجمع مئات من
الصرب امام حكوميه في بلده سفيكان
الحدوديه مع صربيا لمنع رؤساء بلديات
البان منتخبين حديثا من دخول مباني
البلديات لبدء مهامهم قوات من بعثه حفظ
السلام التابعه للناتو اشتركت مع شرطه
كوسوفو في التصدي للمحتجين ومحاوله حمايه
مبنى البلديه في وسط سبيكان
وخلال المواجهات العنيفه اصيب عشرات من
جنود بعثه حفظ السلام الدوليه
ادين بشده الهجمات التي تعرضت لها قوات
حفظ السلام في شمال كوسوفو والتي ادت الى
اصابه 30 منهم بجروح هذه الهجمات غير
مقبوله ويجب ان تتوقف رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
دافع عن الاجراءات التي اتخذتها حكومته في
بلديات شمالي كوسوفو
لا اوافق بشكل اساسي على مشروع القانون
بالسماح بقدر اكبر من الحكم الذاتي
للبلديات الذاتي الاغلبيه الصربيه في
كوسوفو
في الاثناء اعلن الرئيس الصربي ان 52
صربيا اصيب في الاشتباكات مجددا للتاكيد
على وضع قوته في حاله تاهب على الحدود مع
كسوف تطورات المنطقه التي يخشاها الغرب
دفعت منسقه سياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي بمطالبه كسوف وصربيا بوقف
التصعيد الذي وصفه بغير المقبول من جانبها
دعت روسيا حليفه صربيا التاريخي الى
التوقف عن القاء اللوم على السرب الذين
يسعون سلميا للدفاع عن حقوقهم او وفق
قولها مطالبه بخطوات في وقف التصعيد حنان
المصري العربيه
يبدو ان العلاقه بين بغداد واربيل مستمره
بالتوتر فبعد اشكالات الموازنه جاء قرار
المحكمه الاتحاديه بعدم دستوريه تمديد عمل
برلمان اقليم كردستان ليضيف المزيد من
التعقيد على هذه العلاقه
على الرغم من الصوره الايجابيه التي يحاول
الطرفان رسمها الا ان العلاقه المتوتره
بين بغداد واربيل تزداد تعقيدا يوما بعد
اخر ما ان تحل مشكله سياسيه حتى تبدا اخرى
قانونيه اخرها قرار المحكمه الاتحاديه
بعدم دستوريه برلمان اقليم كردستان الحالي
بطلان تمديد عمر برلمان اقليم كردستان
خطوه دستوريه مهمه على اقليم كردستان ان
يلتزم بهذا القرار وحكومه تقليم كردستان
ايضا ستكون حكومه تصريف اعمال من يوم غد
هو يفترض كل القرارات السابقه
تكون ملغيه وقرارات برلمان اقليم كردستان
ايضا قرارات ملغيه ولا تعمل بهذه القرارات
يرى خبراء القانون ان قرار تمديد عمل
برلمان اقليم كردستان هو قرار غير دستوري
وبالتالي فان قرار المح بطلان التمديد
ملزم للسلطات في الاقليم بهذا القرار ملزم
لاقليم كردستان ويوجب ان نكون امام تحديد
موعد لانتخابات برلمان الاقليم تحدد
بالتنسيق بين المفوضيه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات الاتحاديه وبين رئاسه الوزراء
في الاقليم هذه هي الاجواء هنا في
العاصمه اما في اقليم كردستان فالوضع
يختلف تماما ما يهم الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني بزعامه مسعود بارزاني هو اجراء
انتخابات برلمان الاقليم في موعدها المقرر
في نوفمبر المقبل هكذا كان رد الاقليم على
قرار المحكمه الاتحاديه الاخيره ترى ما هو
السيناريو المتوقع لاجراء انتخابات وفق
المواعيد اعتقد انه الحل الامثل في هذه
الحاله هو باللجوء الى السيد رئيس الاقليم
من اجل تفعيل المفوضيه الانتخابات كما
اسلفت وكذلك
ليست لدينا هناك مشكله فيما يتعلق بقانون
انتخابات قانون انتخابات موجود معدل سبع
مرات في اقليم كردستان للخروج من هذه
الازمه الحقيقيه التي تحلق من اقليم اعتقد
انه يجب ان يتم اصدار قرار من قبل رئيس
الاقليم بتفعيل المفوضيه واجراء
الانتخابات الى القانون رقم واحد لسنه
1992 المعدل
اعتماد قانون انتخابات الاقليم لعام
1992 المعدل يبدو انه المخرج الوحيد
للحفاظ على كيان اقليم كردستان العراق
احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفصل
انباء عن توافق جديد على موعد الانتخابات
في ليبيا والمبعوث الامامي ينصح بالمصالحه
اولا
العربيه تعود مجددا لمدينه بيلجرد بعد نصف
عام تقريبا والمشهد هنا تغير بالكامل
هدوء مركز المدينه يشي بالترقب الحذر اذ
اصبح الوضع في باقي مناطق الاقليم
الجنوبيه والغربيه يعيش حاله حرب حقيقيه
وصفها خبراء بالاشج عنفا منذ اندلاعي
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الوضع خطر للغايه مع غياب اجهزه الانذار
المتطوره التنبيه من الضربات ياتي بعد
حدوثها وهذا خطر خاصه ان المنازل متلاصقه
القصف لا يطال مركز مدينه بالقرود لكن
الوضع مقلق بحيث قد تطالون الضربات ونحن
لا نعلم بها اتمنى ان تهدى الامور في
القريب العاجل مدينه
الملاصقتان للشريط الحدودي تنالاني حصه
الاسد من الضربات سلطات بيليجراد اضطرت
لاجلاء قسم كبير من سكان تلك المناطق
وايوائهم في العمر الروسي
الوضع مقلق لكن ليس لحد الخوف الغالبيه
يدركون ان الحرب جاريه ويجب تحمل كل ما
ينتج عنها
القلق على سكان المناطق الحدوديه موجود
فالقذائف لا تميز احدا عن اخر وقد تصيب اي
شخص في الشارع لهذا الوضع بحاجه للتحمل
دون خوف
حصيله الضربات اليوميه على الاقليم خلال
الاسبوع الاخير تتنامى سريعا المنطقه
تتكبد الخسائر الاكبر جراء الصواريخ
وضربات المدفعيه حسب روايه السلطات بينما
تستمر المسيره برشق العبوات الناسفه على
البنيه التحتيه وتنال من شبكات الكهربائي
والاتصال والمياه والغاز والطرقات عبد
الجواد الروشت العربيه
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم
اوكرانيا بتنفيذ هجوم ارهابي بطائرات
المسيره على العاصمه موسكو باستخدام ثمان
مسيرات طالت مباني سكنيه في هدون وقوع ضحى
بشريه
الهجوم بمسيارات يطال العاصمه الروسيه من
جديد ولكنه هذه المره مختلف هجوم مكثف
استهدف ثلاثه مباني سكنيه في قلب موسكو
منذ الصباح الباكر وقدره
في الصباح الباكر حوالي الساعه الخامسه
استيقظت على اثر صوت يقترب من بيتنا على
الرغم من اننا نعيش في الطبق الثالث عشر
كان مفاجئا لاننا لم نعتد ان نسمع مثل هذه
الاصوات ثم سمعنا صوت الصدام وتحطم الزجاج
اضرارا على الرغم من انها ليست بالكبيره
خلفها الهجوم على العاصمه لكنها ادخلت
الخوف الى كل بيت فيها وتساؤلات حول حجم
التهديدات التي يمكن ان يتعرض لها سكان
المدن الروسيه مع اتساع رقعه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
انا لا اخاف ابدا الكرملين على لسان
متحدثه اكد على ان نظام كيف هو من يقف
وراء هذا الهجوم بالمسيرات على العاصمه
معتبرا انه رد اوكراني على ضربه فعاله
شنتها موسكو على احد مراكز صنع القرار في
اوكرانيا العربيه موسكو
وقد اعتبر الرئيس الروسيا الهجوم على
موسكو جاء ردا على ضربه روسيه على مقر
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه ويهدف
الى ترهيب السكان بوتين اشارى الى انظمه
الدفاع روسيه تصدت بكفاءه للهجوم
لم نطلق العنان لهذه الحرب في عام 2014
اختار نظام كييف معادله روسيا واضطهاد
الروس في دون باس ونحن لا نستخدم هذه
الوسائل التي يستخدمها قاده نظام كييف وما
حدث اليوم تاكيد اخر على ذلك المنشات
المدنيه السلميه في موسكو تعرضت للاستهداف
وعلى العكس من ممارسات الجيش الاوكراني
تنفذ قواتنا ضربات دقيقه ضد منشات البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه ومنها مقر المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الذي تعرض للقصف قبل
يومين او ثلاثه ايام اختار نظام كييف
مسارا مختلفا مسار محاولات ترهيب روسيا
وتخويف المواطنين الروس وضرب المباني
السكنيه وهذه بالطبع علامه واضحه على نشاط
ارهابي
حرب المسيرات اضحت الوجه البارزه للمواجهه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كل طرف يسعى الاستهداف
عاصمه الاخر بعدها هجمات متواصله على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه هجوم جديد استهدف
موسكو بالمسيرات فرضيتان اثنتان بخصوص
الهجوم الاوكراني الفرضيه الاولى تتمثل في
استهداف موسكو وانطلاقا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه خاصه من سومي وهي منطقه تبعد
عن موسكو حوالي 600 كيلومتر الفرضيه
الثانيه تشير الى تنفيذ الهجمات من داخل
الاراضي الروسيه ما يعني وجود خلايا نائمه
داخل التراب الروسي خبراء اشار الى ان
الطرفين يمتلكان مسيرات دواره وذات الجناح
الثابت والانتحاريه ابرز المسيرات التي
تمتلكها كياف طائره اوكرانيه الصنع يبلغ
طول جناحها اثنتين وثلاثين قدما وتستطيع
الطيران لسبع ساعات وتصل سرعتها الى 100
ميلي بالساعه
امريكيه الصنع تطير لمده ست ساعات بسرعه
100 ميل في الساعه فضلا عن المسيرات
التركيه الصنع برقدار من طراز تي بي اثنان
والتي يبلغ طولها سته امتار ونصف تحمل
اربع ذخائر موجهه بالليزر روسيا هي الاخرى
اضحت متقدمه مؤخرا في تصنيع الطائرات
المسيره ثابته الجناح كطائرات اوريان التي
يبلغ طولها 14 مترا وتستطيع الطيران لمده
24 ساعه متواصله بسرعه 120 ميلا بالساعه
اضافه الى المسيرات ايرانيه الصنع التي
تبلغ سرعتها
185 كيلومترا بالساعه وهي كبيره الحجم لكن
صنعها منخفض الكلفه تبلغ هدفها بواسطه
احداثيات نظام جي بي اس يتم ادخالها قبل
اقلاعها وتحلق بعدها في شكل ذاتي على علو
منخفض تصل هدفها الثابته بالضروره على بعد
بضع مئات الكيلومترات بلال الوجداني
العربيه
وزير الدفاع
روسيسانه القوات الروسيه تتكيف بسرعه مع
التهديدات وترفع من قدرات الطيران مضيفا
ان دعم حلف الناتو بالاسلحه لاوكرانيا
سيؤدي لاطاله الانشطه العسكريه
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا لا يؤدي الا
لاطاله الانشطه العسكريه الى ابعد من ذلك
ولكن لا يمكن ان يؤثر على نتيجه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه وباستخدام اسلحه النيتو
يواصل منهم على راس السلطه في كييف شن
ضربات ضد المرافق الاجتماعيه وارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه ضد المدنيين الروس وقواتنا
العسكريه حازمه في ردها على تصرفات
المسلحين الاوكرانيين
اما البيت الابيض فقد علق على الهجمات
بالطائرات مسيره التي استهدفت موسكو وقال
ان واشنطن لا تؤيد الهجوم على روسيا كما
كاد البيت الابيض انه لا يزال يجمع
المعلومات بشان هجوم الطائرات مسيره
الاخير على موسكو وشدد على انه يدعم
اوكرانيا لاستعاده اراضيها فقط
الطائره المسيره التركيه بيرقدار تي بي 2
كانت من ابرز ما استخدمته اوكرانيا في
بدايه الحرب استخدمت المسيره خلال العديد
من العمليات المسلحه المهمه كتعطيل
الاليات العسكريه الروسيه الاتيه من
بيلاروسيا او تدمير الطراد الروسي موسكو
على الجانب الاخر تمطر موسكو بانتظام
العمق الاوكراني بمسيارات المتفجره من
طراز شاهد ايرانيه الصنع او ما تعرف
بالمسيرات الانتحاريه وبما انها اقل كلفه
فهي تستخدم من كلا الجانبين في محاوله
لاستنفاذ الدفاعات الجويه للطرف الاخر يتم
استخدام غالبيه المسيرات قرب الجبهه
لاهداف الاستطلاع او شن هجمات باستخدام
طائرات مسيره صغيره تجاريه يتم تعديلها
لهذا الغرض حدوث تحرك على جبهه معينه
سيعطي دورا اكبر للطائرات دون طيار التي
بمقدورها المشاركه في المعارك
اكد المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفيع الروسي ان وضع الامن والسلامه
النوويه في محطه زباروجيا الاوكرانيه
للطاقه النوويه لا يزال هشا وخطيرا للغايه
مضيفا انه لحسن الحظ لم يقع حادث نووي حتى
الان ومؤكدا على انه يجب بذل كل الجهود
لتقليل فرصه حدوث ذلك واعتبر جروسي في
فائده امام مجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده ان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت
مستمره في المنطقه وقد تزيد بشكل كبير في
المستقبل القريب
قالت وسائل اعلام ليبيه ان لجنه سته زائد
سته المشتركه من اعضاء البرلمان ومجلس
الدوله اتفقت على تشكيل حكومه مصغره لمده
سته اشهر لتنظيم الانتخابات وشهرت الى
التوافق على اجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه
في ديسمبر المقبل والراسيه في يناير 2024
كما اكدت تقارير الليبيه ان اللجنه سمحت
بترشح العسكريين ومزدوجي الجنسيه
للانتخابات وعدم السماح لمن عليه حكم
قضائي او مطلوب للعداله كذلك اتفقت اللجنه
على تقسيم مقاعد البرلمان لتكون 60%
للاحزاب واربعين في المئه للافراد
في نهايه نشره تسكيرهم بابرز العناوين
المركبه دراغون تعود الى الارض وعلى متنها
رائد فضاء سعوديين بعد رحله استغرقت عشره
ايام بهدف اجراء تجارب علميه
قانون سقف الدين يمر بلجنه القواعد في
انتظار تصويت مجلس النواب ثم مجلس الشيوخ
والصيدله دوليه كوريا الشماليه تقول ان
قمر الاستطلاع العسكري الذي اطلقته تحطم
في البحر
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات